well there is already Anger from some
senior local government leaders that
it's a betrayal of cities like
Birmingham and Manchester and uh calls
into question the government's whole
leveling up agenda now what has happened
is that Mark Harper the transport
secretary has at the very end of Commons
business on Thursday and the house is
not sitting tomorrow he has produced a
written statement a written statement
hasn't turned up in the House of Commons
to deliver an oral statement and face
questions from MPS he has delivered a
written statement including this news
about hs2 there has in the last couple
of minutes between being an angry
protest from a labor MP Sarah Owen
complaining about how Mr Harper has
sought did not see fit to come to the
house she said this is out an outrageous
attempt to avoid scrutiny and Nigel
Evans the deputy speaker has more or
less agreed with her and said that the
house is not sitting tomorrow and he
said there has to be an expectation that
MPS will have the opportunity to
question ministers on the statement in
other words uh Mr the speaker Lindsay
Hall is going to allow an urgent
question on Monday let me just take you
through the key bits of Mr Harper's
written statement now it begins critics
would say laughably with the words hs2
is making good progress talks about how
much money's been spent 20 billion on
phase one London the West Midlands and
so on number of jobs and so on the
government is prioritizing Mr Harper
says hs2's initial Services between old
oak common in London that's to the west
of London and Birmingham curzen Street
to provide delivery of Passenger
benefits as soon as possible now on
Euston Station he says this we remain
committed to delivering hs2 services is
to Houston and will address
affordability pressures to ensure the
overall spending profile is manageable
we will therefore take the time to
ensure we have an affordable and
deliverable station design delivering
Houston along high-speed infrastructure
to Manchester it talk and then the key
bit about Birmingham and crew it's the
government says it is committed to
delivering hs2 between crew we have seen
significant inflationary pressure and
increased project costs and so we will
re-phase construction by two years
rephased in other words delay with an
aim to deliver high-speed services to
crew in the Northwest as soon as
possible after accounting for the delay
in construction this is just days before
the budget this is the chancellor
imposing a massive squeeze on Capital
spending across Whitehall and the
clearly the treasury wanted this out in
the open before budget day so there was
the massive route about hs2 on budget
day well there is going to be a big row
because opponents are Furious some Tory
MPS will who are opposed to it will say
why not scrap the whole thing but the
government's insisted it's going ahead
it's just slowing it down putting the
brakes on it and major parts of it are
now in some doubt including the
redevelopments of Houston Station